herzlich willkommen zur folge 202 des
faz einspruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast für recht justiz und politik
heute am 16 märz 2022 mein name ist
corinna budras ich bin berlin
korrespondent in der faz und mit dabei
ist wieder wie halo renz freie
journalisten und juristen aus köln 9 ja
und wir melden uns diesmal wieder aus
dem homeoffice also ich namentlich auch
du bist ja immer aber
ich für mich ist es anders heute denn
vielleicht hört man ein bisschen ich bin
noch verschnupft denn ja ich habe krone
und bin deswegen musste ich mich ab
sondern sitze also zu hause und es ist
wieder so wie vor einem jahr als wir das
ganz regelmäßig gemacht haben und ich
mein schönes mischpult noch nicht hatte
ja und das vermisse ich jetzt ehrlich
gesagt wahnsinnig und man fühlt sich
doch ein wenig nackte und hat die ganze
zeit angst dass das technisch alles
nicht so funktioniert also bitte daumen
drücken wir schaffen ja
[Gelächter]
corona ist übrigens auch wirklich ein
ganz gutes stichwort
es ist mal wieder soweit ja denn wir
werden uns heute nicht um den krieg in
der ukraine kümmern was mir natürlich
gesagt auch so ein bisschen im herz
blutet weil es natürlich etwas ist ein
thema ist dass uns die ganze zeit
wahnsinnig umtreibt und wo ich auch
sicher bin dass der wissensdurst noch
lange nicht gestillt ist aber wir haben
ja letzte woche eine wirklich sehr lange
sendung zu dem thema gemacht da bitte
auch gerne noch mal reinhören und heute
müssen wir uns dem
infektionsschutzgesetz
widmen
und zwar in aller ausführlichkeit
sozusagen wir haben uns das mal relativ
genau angeschaut was uns da jetzt
eigentlich auf bundesebene und auf
länderebene
erwartet und du corinna hast ja auch
noch die neue arbeitsschutzverordnung
angeschaut die auch ab dem zwanzigsten
dritten gilt also das heißt und was wie
sieht's denn jetzt eigentlich in den
unternehmen aus
also das ist ehrlich gesagt alles mit
dem
hoffentlich mit dem wir uns beschäftigen
in dieser sendung es geht rauf und
runter wir räumen auch doch mit einigen
fehlinterpretationen auf so möchte ich
mal sagen in der politik ging es ja
wirklich in den letzten tagen hoch her
die aufregung war riesig aber wenn man
sich das dann doch mal näher zu gemüte
führt kann man sagen das ist schon eine
regel die uns jetzt nicht komplett
schutzlos lässt und auf der anderen
seite aber vielleicht auch den
situationen gerecht wird dass wir ja in
einer anderen welt leben das ist jetzt
auch ganz viele leute gibt die geimpft
sind und die sich womöglich auch noch
impfen lassen das ist natürlich noch der
zweite aspekt in diesem ganzen chor ohne
block den wir uns widmen wollen die
impfpflicht kerner am donnerstag in
erster lesung im bundestag und wir haben
uns die fünf anträge mal angeschaut die
da bisher vorliegen und dann sind wir
schon bei den nachträgen genau beim
nachtrag und dann haben wir noch
natürlich das gerechte urteilt das ist
ja wohl auch nicht besonders launig wie
du gestern schon so schön gesagt was
aber sehr sehr gerecht genau
diese launige sendung es tut uns
wirklich leid aber jetzt gehen wir mal
rein
[Musik]
und legen los mit der neuregelung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes über die am
heutigen nachmittag wir zeichnen auf am
mittwochmorgen der bundestag in
debattieren wird also corinna legen wir
mal langsam los und versuchen das
irgendwie zu sortieren wie geht es denn
jetzt eigentlich ab nächste woche weiter
genau wir hatten ja vielleicht noch mal
kurz zur genese des gesetzes folgenden
situationen das im herbst als die letzte
große änderungs welle über uns
hereinbrach ja schon festgelegt dass die
ganzen maßnahmen bis zum 19 märz
auslaufen das steht ihm in dem
infektionsschutzgesetz so drin und
deswegen muss jetzt also auch der
bundestag tätig werden es war faktisch
keine optionen das ganze jetzt laufen zu
lassen das muss man ehrlicherweise sagen
und er wird ja noch recht spät tätig da
gibt es ja auch schon karriere viel
gemeckert aus da jetzt relativ wenig
optionen bestehen auf den letzten
drücker noch was zu ende genau und es
war nämlich etwas was sich letzte woche
schon angekündigt hatte am mittwoch sind
karl lauterbach der gesundheitsminister
und der justizminister marco buschmann
vor die presse getreten und haben
gemeinsam ihre änderungen vorgestellt in
größter harmonie was insofern auch
bemerkenswert ist weil ich glaube
tatsächlich stets minister marco
buschmann damit ziemlich
klare rolle einnimmt und auch einen dem
möchte im gegensatz zu der ministerin zu
vorne also frau christine lambrecht in
der spd hatte natürlich auch hin und
wieder war das eine oder andere zu sagen
aber jedenfalls diese ganzen infektions
das ganze infektionsschutzgesetz war
natürlich auf ganz anderer ebene also
damals gesundheitsminister sparen und
dann eben die kanzlerin also das war
relativ fest in deren hand aber jetzt
haben wir ein fdp-minister der sehr klar
die linie durch bringen möchte die linie
seiner partei durch bringen möchte und
deswegen hatten wir da dieses gemeinsame
auftreten und das interessante war ja
auch dass es wirklich also ein
kompromiss war der schon seit wochen
geschmiedet wurde und dann wirklich auf
den letzten metern erst ja
offensichtlich zu geschnürt werden
konnte es gab wirklich merkwürdige sehen
zb dass die verbände nachts um 1 uhr
sie den vorläufigen entwurf bekommen
haben mit der bitte um stellungnahme ich
glaub es neun oder zehn uhr morgens
das kostet ja
da waren die natürlich entsetzt und wer
sich das wirklich mal angeschaut hat und
ich empfehle es jeden wir tun's auch
gerne in die show notes der wird merken
dass das wirklich kein vergnügen er ist
sich dadurch zu wälzen ist es übrigens
nie bei neuen gesetzen er war natürlich
ist einfach nicht besonders appetitlich
präsentiert aber dass er hat ja alles
besser denn in zukunft gibt es doch sein
ob sie es wird alles ja aber wann ja das
ist eine gute frage ich habe davon noch
nichts über liebe pia genau das ist ja
auch ein vorhaben von marco buschmann
aber hier ist es jedenfalls nicht so
sondern es wird einfach nur aufgelistet
was geändert wird und das ist mitunter
sehr mühselig zu lesen also das war
jetzt die letzte woche und jetzt kommen
wir aber zu dem was da auch mal da
tatsächlich drin zu finden ist das
wichtigste und das was jetzt allen voran
geht ist eigentlich die übergangsfrist
bis zum zweiten april das war's also
schon mal mit dem frida
also den räumen wir jetzt mal komplett
ab übrigens haben wir auch sehr
freundliche zuschrift auch zu diesem
thema bekommen auch von einer höheren
die gesagt hat sie hat immer
bauchschmerzen wenn sie diesen begriff
hört weil das natürlich sonst immer in
ganz anderen kontext spielt natürlich
viel dramatischer sind als das was wir
jetzt gerade erlebt haben also fehlen
darf absolut
das würden wir wenn es uns mal wieder
herausrutscht was ich bei mir nicht
garantieren kann dann
jedenfalls bitte mit denken das ist
jetzt hier natürlich er eigentlich
geschuldet ist der tatsache dass das
öfter einfach benutzt wurde in diesem
zusammenhang aber ein freedom day wird
es jetzt am 20 märz nicht geben
jedenfalls nicht jenseits der
unternehmen also aber da kommen wir
gleich noch dazu genau dann vielleicht
erst mal zeitlich es gibt jetzt
übergangsfrist genau bis zum zweiten
vierten wo im wesentlichen alle
maßnahmen bis auf die kontakt
beschränkung weiterlaufen können das
heißt wir reden hier vor allen dingen
über die masken pflicht in enormen im
öffentlichen nahverkehr wir reden über
3g regelungen in den gaststätten zb oder
wo auch immer sie gelten
und oder auch zwei gelungen all das ist
ja bisher möglich und wird auch weiter
möglich sein wir müssen die
landesregierung nur einfach beschließen
dass sie das so machen wollen haben
jetzt auch etliche gemacht die meisten
bis zum 24 einige wie berlin auch bis
zum 31 was ich jetzt dahinter wieder
verbirgt ring immer mit sondern
beschlüssen im abgeordnetenhaus zusammen
man will ja auch nicht alles ganz genau
wissen aber bis dahin jedenfalls gilt
erstmal alles wie gehabt und danach gäbe
es auch noch die möglichkeit
hotspots zu verkünden also ab dem 24
werden wir dann tatsächlich in einer
einigermaßen neuen welt leben die
aufgebaut ist in einen sogenannten
basisschutz denen die länder dann
verhängen müssen auch in ihren
jeweiligen ländern auch da haben sie
dann wieder spielraum und es gibt eine
zweite
hotspot regelung also einem eine
sozusagen eine verschärfte regelung wo
wieder der
maßnahmenkatalog geöffnet werden kann
auch hier wieder eigentlich der ganze
maßnahmenkatalog bis auf die kontakt
beschränkung vielleicht noch ein kurzes
wort nicht wir sind ja schon relativ
abgespeckt in den maßnahmenkatalog mir
was wir ja auch schon gar nicht mehr
haben sind die ausgangssperren die
beherbergungs verbote die reiseverbote
all das sind ja so maßnahmen die sich
noch die noch dann gezogen werden können
wenn es eine epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite gibt ja auch das
war ja eine debatte die wir mehr herbst
rauf und runter geführt haben aber im
moment stehen diese instrumente nicht
zur verfügung und werden natürlich auch
nicht die
klubs sind ja schon wieder offen wenn
auch mit 2g plus es gibt in der
gastronomie gibt es nicht mehr zwei
sondern nur noch 3g seit anfang märz das
ist ja alles schon ein wenig auf
gelockert worden das heißt aber in den
hotspots kann vieles von dem was die
ländern derzeit machen können auch
weiterhin verhängt werden richtig kennen
und vielleicht fangen wir tatsächlich
auch mal mit den hot spots an sind hot
spots die neuen risikogebiete
kann man eigentlich so nicht so richtig
sagen denn also eigentlich die mit den
risikogebieten hat sich ja dann nicht so
wahnsinnig viel verbunden oder also ist
eine interessante frage aber ich würde
doch mal sagen das ist jetzt hier eine
neue nomenklatur an die wir uns
gewöhnen müssen was ist denn ein hotspot
überhaupt wann wird er dann ausgerufen
also der kann nur ausgerufen werden von
dem jeweiligen länder parlament auch
hier war es wieder sehr wichtig die
parlamente 1 bin und nicht die regierung
da ganz alleine schalten und walten zu
lassen das ist ja der fdp aber auch den
grünen immer sehr wichtig gewesen
und hier muss geht das nur dann ein
hotspot liegt nur dann vor wenn es
entweder eine neue mutante gibt einen
neuen virus eine virusvariante und zwar
mit signifikant höherer pathogenität ein
wort das ich auch erstmal lernen musste
er nicht mehr man nur so dunkel was es
sein könnte geht im wesentlichen darum
dass diese variante die menschen kränker
machen muss als bisher ja also man so
schlimmer ist irgendwie noch schlimmer
ist als
omikron so habe ich es ist auch übrigens
interessant es geht schon los ja also da
streiten sich natürlich die juristen das
ist auch wirklich ein gefundenes fressen
für die juristen weil auch da natürlich
viele unbestimmte rechtsbegriffe auch
sehr zur diskussion führen und man immer
diskutieren kann ja was ist jetzt damit
gemeint ist jetzt die höhere
pathogenität bezogen auf den wild typen
das kann man wohl auf jeden fall sagen
oder auf omikron dann wäre man
vielleicht auch schon leichter dabei
weil er von omikron ist ja immer heißt
das sie milder ist diese virus variante
naja also jedenfalls ist das noch eine
möglichkeit das auszufüllen mit vielen
diskussionen und womöglich
rechtsstreitigkeiten es gibt aber auch
noch eine zweite voraussetzung die
gezogen werden kann oder die
dazu führt dass ein hotspot vor liegt
nämlich bei überlastung der krankenhaus
kapazitäten in einer jeweiligen
gebietskörperschaft ja und da da gibt es
keine konkreten zahlen also genau keine
internen oder keine keine
hospitalisierung rate oder whatever
sondern das steht da im moment relativ
in konkreten ja und auch das war eben
eine sehr bewusste entscheidung weil man
eben gesagt hat naja also jetzt haben
wir doch schon ein paar virusvarianten
erlebt und haben festgestellt dass sie
sehr unterschiedlich wüten in der
bevölkerung ja dass man hier eben bei
gerade bei uni kommen sind weil bei ganz
anderen zahlen aber die trotzdem sind
die krankenhäuser noch nicht so voll wie
es eben zu den schlimmsten zeiten von
alpha beta oder data war ja also
insofern ist das vielleicht gar keine so
doofe idee zu sagen da wollen wir keinen
festen rahmen vorgeben dieses gesetz
soll eben schmiede sein soll flexibel
sein sodass man
anwenden kann und man muss ja offen
gestehen dass ja die
gerichte da oft auch mitgegangen sind
bei diesen flexiblen
möglichkeiten haben auch den gesetzgeber
matschie spielraum gelassen also
vielleicht ist das auch wirklich nicht
die dümmste variante was übrigens in der
diskussion immer so ein bisschen
untergeht ist dass das erklärt werden
muss für die gebietskörperschaften und
auch da kann man vielleicht einmal
deutlich sagen auch das ist ein extrem
flexible begriff also das können kreise
seien also städte seien
gemeinden seien aber auch das bundesland
als solches ja das macht die sache
natürlich einfacher das länderparlament
sagt also hier ich greife jetzt mal
zufällig sachsen raus hier in sachsen
ist die situation generell so brenzlig
und da hilft es uns auch nicht dass es
zwei
gemeinden gibt oder zwei landkreise
wurde alles ein bisschen entspannter ist
ja hier im ganzen land gucken wir mit
argwohn auf die überlastung der
krankenhaus kapazitäten und deswegen
verhängen wir für das gesamte bundesland
ein hotspot das ist durchaus möglich und
wäre eine sehr einfache handhabung
dessen das ganze geht dann übrigens für
drei monate ja das muss man auch mal
feststellen also da ist dann
lustigerweise von diesem sehr flexiblen
ansatz dann wiederum nicht mehr richtig
zu sehen sein wenn der landtag würde
natürlich den hot spot selbst wieder
aufheben das könnte schon machen aber
wenn sie nichts tun dann ist ein
landkreis eine was auch immer eine
gebietskörperschaft erst mal für drei
monate eine hot ein hotspot und dann
steht weiterhin ein relativ weiter
instrumentenkasten zur verfügung war es
an carola maßnahmen verhängt werden und
dann kommen die länder regierung wieder
ins spiel denn die sind ja diejenigen
die tatsächlich die verordnung dann
erlassen die also die maßnahme sich
raussuchen und für diese jeweiligen
gebietskörperschaft
womöglich eben für das gesamte
bundesland festlegen das ist der
mechanismus und diese verordnung
übrigens wiederum die geht nur für vier
wochen ja also das war der mechanismus
die werden jetzt die ganze zeit gesehen
haben aber
jedenfalls diese feststellung muss nur
einmal getroffen werden für einen
zeitraum von drei monaten die verordnung
müsste dann immer nach vier wochen
spätestens angepasst werden vielleicht
noch einmal zusammenfassend wie sieht
denn jetzt der instrumentenkasten aus
oder vielleicht anders rum wie sieht
denn nicht mehr aus also es kommt ja
jetzt schon ganz schön viel gemecker aus
den ländern die sagen jetzt nehmen die
uns schon wieder noch mehr instrumente
beck das ist ja alles viel zu gefährlich
die inzidenz sind noch zu hoch wir
können ja gar nichts mehr machen ist das
jetzt wirklich so dramatisch
das einzige was tatsächlich wegfällt
sind die kontakt beschränkung ja dann
aber ich muss auch gestehen wäre
interessant zu wissen in der praxis
welchen einfluss sie eigentlich noch
gehabt haben denn die gab es ja jetzt
eine ganze zeit lang über für ungeimpfte
ja ich frag mich persönlich ob sie das
überhaupt gemerkt haben ja ja ich auch
genau also ob sich daran tatsächlich
irgendjemand gehalten hat gerade jemand
der ungeimpft ist also daran habe ich
auch so meine zweifel aber
gut das ist jedenfalls das was definitiv
wegfällt wie sieht es denn aus mit 2g 3g
schlag mit zugangsbeschränkungen die
können weiterhin wie bisher verhängt
werden also auch da ist der mechanismus
ganz klar es wird in eine
möglichkeit geben führt zum beispiel den
gastwirt nach solchen test nachweisen
test im chinesen reisen zu fragen und
dann wird es auch die möglichkeit geben
oder es wird er gezwungen sein
die zugangsbeschränkung zu erteilen also
dann leute einfach schlicht ergreifend
nicht rein zu lassen also das ist der
mechanismus wie gehabt so kleine notiz
am rande das war bisher schlecht
formuliert in einem der ersten entwurf
auch das sorgte für aufregung aber
jedenfalls gestern hat mir die spd
zugesagt dass das behoben wird und dass
das wie bisher
funktionieren soll wir haben ein kleines
sonderproblem noch bei den personen
obergrenzen in hygienepläne also wir
haben was ja auch total interessant ist
ist ja die frage nach
großveranstaltungen also kann es in
hotspots volle fußballstadien und voll
konzerte geben und da sagt er die
regierung ganz klar nein wird es nicht
geben und zwar nicht etwa weil es jetzt
eine person obergrenze gibt die hat mir
bisher eine veranstaltung bis zu 5000
leute oder so können abgehalten werden
oder so aber diese obergrenzen werden
auch verschwinden aber was es natürlich
weiterhin geben wird sind hygienepläne
für veranstalter und also die
das wäre dann also vor allem
großveranstaltungen sehr detailliert mit
hygiene konzepten versehen werden müssen
und da werden die personen obergrenzen
rein gerechnet oder was die müssen ja
sehr eng mit den gesundheitsämtern
abgestimmt werden diese gene pläne ist
ja wirklich echt auch glaube ich nicht
ganz trivial sowas zu machen da wird
dann darauf geachtet wie das mit den
abstands geboten ist und so weiter und
da in diesem zuge kann man natürlich
auch sagen also in diese und jede halle
können
können eben nur soundsoviel leute wenn
wir darauf achten dass der abstand
gewahrt wird im zuge dessen auch da
wieder ist es flexibler als vorher aber
nicht komplett schutzlos dann also jetzt
haben wir keine starre obergrenze mehr
sondern am jeweiligen
an der jeweiligen situation ausgerichtet
eine art der veranstaltung und an der
größe der räumlichkeiten und so weiter
und so fort also das ist jedenfalls der
mechanismus wie hier gedacht es wird
interessant sein inwieweit das auch wie
der praxis kümmern genau weil wenn jetzt
die länder keinen hotspot ausrufen oder
nur teilweise hotspots ausrufen oder so
was geht denn dann jetzt in zucker dann
haben wir eben den basisschutz die
möglichkeiten die die bundesländer dann
nutzen können sind da relativ beschränkt
und das war ja auch der teil der hier am
meisten für ärger gesorgt hat und auch
für die meisten diskussionen noch kurz
vor toresschluss also wie gesagt gestern
war noch viel im schwange war noch wurde
noch viel rumgedreht an den einzelnen
formulierungen und da geht es im
wesentlichen immer um die masken pflicht
vielleicht noch einmal klar gesagt was
ist dieser basis schutz der konzentriert
sich jetzt auf eine maske schlich und
eine testpflicht bei den variablen
gruppen ja und zwar natürlich
krankenhäuser natürlich pflegeheime
ambulante pflegedienste
arztpraxen rettungsdienst das sind so
die situation wo natürlich getestet
werden kann natürlich auch mundschutz
getragen werden muss und zwar von 1 so
aber wenn ich jetzt nächste woche in
supermarkt ihre da muss ich keine maske
tragen also wenn der fragen wir
vielleicht ein wenig ein wenig anders
wahrscheinlich erst ab dem 24 denn ab
nächste das ist unwahrscheinlich dass
ich das schon ändert aber das heißt dann
kann ich ohne maske in den supermarkt
kinder also was für streit sorgte war
tatsächlich die masken pflicht in den
innenräumen ja die eigentlich spd und
grüne überall frankart wollten und zwar
egal ob im baumarkt oder im supermarkt
oder wie auch immer ja die wollten
einfach eine generelle masse pflicht und
da hat die fdp nicht mitgemacht das
heißt ein basisschutz ist es tatsächlich
nur gibt es nur eine maske schlicht bei
den variablen gruppen und nicht und
nicht in supermärkten übrigens auch
nicht in schulen das muss man auch sehen
in schulen zum beispiel nicht auch das
sorgte ja immer für großen ärger ich
meine nichts ist in der pandemie so
umstritten gewesen wie die masken
pflicht so bekloppt es klingt ein mann
geht denn viele viele leute die auch
sagen das ist der geringste eingriff er
war das kann ich auch schon
nachvollziehen zu sagen wir mal so in
vielerlei hinsicht der in oder in vielen
beim supermarkt ehrlich gesagt stört
mich dazu nicht aber man muss sagen acht
stunden in der schule ist schon einiges
verlangt zone und auch dass wenn jetzt
also keine hotspot regelung angewendet
wird das entfällt jetzt keine massen
pflicht mehr für die kids in der schule
genau richtig okay wie sieht es denn in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln aus
öffentlicher verkehrsmittel ist auch so
eine traum
regelung
weil die gilt direkt
in dem fernverkehr und war in den
flugzeugen also also die masken
fernseher die massen auf bundesebene im
fernverkehr korrekt da bleibt jena
da bleibt es auf jeden fall das kann
verankert werden im 28b
infektionsschutzgesetz weil der bund
zuständig ist für für den fern und den
kindern richtig dann gibt es aber noch
eine regelung für den psv auch dieser
die masken schlicht im op en v ist im
basisschutz vorhanden also grundsätzlich
kann man jetzt sagen auch in den bussen
und bahnen müssen masken getragen werden
aber übrigens auch da wieder das müssen
die länder auch dann zu hängen also was
übrigens total denkbar wäre auch wenn
man das in der aufgeregten diskussion
nicht glaubt wäre dass die länder dann
für sich entscheiden oder ein land sich
entscheidet ach wir nehmen übrigens noch
nicht mal den basisschutz das geht auch
ach guck mal süße das wollen wir jetzt
auch noch gar nicht da das heißt wir
nehmen gar nichts gar nichts gar nichts
denn es heißt ja im 28
absatz 7 heißes jahr unabhängig von
dieser epidemischen lage die wm
nationaler tragweite
können folgende maßnahmen verhängt
werden und wer hat diesen mechanismus
hat mir die ganze zeit ist haben wir
immer die länder regierung die
verordnung erst noch umsetzen müssen
also nicht gesagt deswegen ändert sich
daran gar nichts ja aber ich sage es
hier noch einmal explizit dass die
länder das tatsächlich dann auch
tatsächlich umsetzen müssten also wir
haben hier ziemlich breiten
korridor noch an möglichkeiten team
vorsicht kann ehrlich gesagt für die
nächsten drei monate ab dem 24
hotspots regeln wo immer es will ja die
cam voraussetzungen dafür vorliegen wenn
die voraussetzungen da vorliegende und
gibt es natürlich auch länder die sagen
aber die sind so schwammig formuliert
und klar laufen unsere krankenhäuser
gerade voll aber die rechtsunsicherheit
die rechtsunsicherheit aber ich muss mal
ganz offen gestehen ja also meine
erfahrung ist ja eigentlich bisher das
sieht es dann verhängen und das ist dann
vor den gerichten eher schwieriger ist
seine sachen wieder rückabwickeln zu
lassen will sagen also ich rechne er
damit dass wenn ein bundesland diesen
weg beschreiten will es ihnen auch den
beschreiten wird und dann wahrscheinlich
also auf absehbare zeit jetzt erstmal
nicht zurückgepfiffen wird
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen also das
als wäre interessant zu sehen ist
natürlich jetzt hier alles im fluss eine
aber kann man sich vorstellen dass so
ein verwaltungsgericht dann ankommt und
sagt ja die hotspot regelung
ist aber zu nicht nicht genug begründet
und deswegen im eilverfahren
werde jetzt mal haben wir das management
kann sich das also ich will es auch gar
nicht
komplett ausschließen aber also gemessen
daran dass wir 90 prozent der der
maßnahmen immer bestätigt wurden
eigentlich sogar unter baut das war ja
man das was man jetzt gesehen hat in den
letzten zwei jahren also wer spannend
also wer mal eine interessante
diskussion ist natürlich wäre jetzt auch
insofern höchstwert weil diese hotspot
regelung natürlich auch mit
ernsthaftigkeit benutzt werden sollen
ist jetzt auch kein freifahrtschein also
so ein bisschen
überlegungen muss man da schon rein
geben also einfach nur den verhängen und
keine begründung nachliefern so geht es
natürlich nicht aber ich glaube ja
durchaus dass angesichts der derzeitigen
instanzen sehr viele länder diesen hot
spot ziehen werden und das ist das
vielleicht auch so ein bisschen erklärt
warum zum beispiel gesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach jetzt noch relativ
entspannt wirkt obwohl viele leute sagen
oh i der basisschutz wir haben ja fast
gar keine instrumente mehr nur also karl
lauterbach sagt ja und auch nicht zu
unrecht die länder können es ja ziehen
wo es erforderlich ist und ich glaube
man kann auch davon ausgehen dass das
passieren wird und deshalb ist glaube
ich auch die die spd und auch die grünen
sind da schon noch einigermaßen
entspannt insgesamt ausnahme vielleicht
eben ein bisschen die masken pflicht den
basisschutz also da könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass vielleicht sogar noch
was naja ich also ich glaube ehrlich
gesagt drops ist gelutscht
also alles was man eben so hört auch von
der spd und den grünen natürlich finden
sind die damit nicht hundertprozentig
zufrieden
gestern aus der spd hieß das ist ein
gesamtkunstwerk das vielleicht in
einigen stellen nicht ganz gelungen ist
wie sie es fand aber wie gesagt der kern
der diskussion und der
auseinandersetzung bezieht sich auf die
maske schlecht ja also es ist wirklich
nicht so als würde das ganze konstrukt
jetzt und schwanken geraten oder von
allen diskutiert werden weil es eben ja
dann doch wirklich noch etliche
maastricht bleiben die die länder ziehen
können wenn sie sich für eine hotspot
regelung entscheiden aber die wie gesagt
ist so ein bisschen begründung
intensiver sagen wir mal so aber
vielleicht ein watt jetzt zu den
betriebsstätten also wir sagen zum zu
den unternehmen also und den
mitarbeitern dabei das scheint mir
tatsächlich die grösste veränderung zu
sein und zwar ab dem 20 die hat auch
keine übergangsregelung die hat keine
übrigens regelung also die ist die neue
arbeitsschutzverordnung übrigens genau
das liegt ihm genau daran dass das
wesentliche in der
arbeitsschutzverordnung
geregelt ist die heute am mittwoch vom
kabinett beschlossen
werden soll und voraussichtlich auch
durchgehend genau das ist wie gesagt
eine verordnung die wird nur im kabinett
beschlossen die muss nicht mehr durch
den bundestag mehr anders als die
optionsregelung die jetzt alle noch
durchgewunken werden genau und da haben
wir relativ klar es gibt kein home
office pflicht mehr das heißt die
unternehmen können ihre mitarbeiter
zurückbeordern und werden es eigentlich
wahrscheinlich auch tun viele jedenfalls
dann gibt es kein 3g mehr und das
übrigens findet auch einige sehr
bedauerlich
auch das ist so ein bisschen oder da
gibt es ja auch wirklich relativ viel
schutz muss man ja mal sagen wenn ich
meine auch als unternehmen hat man ja
eigentlich kein interesse daran dass
sich dass man irgendwie infektionsherd
wird und sich dadurch
von mitarbeitenden anstecken für die
unternehmen echt gesagt war es sehr
angenehm weil die eben deutlich machen
konnten also so und so sind die regeln
also wir wollen ja eigentlich kann ich
aber wir müssen jetzt mal hier kurz
gucken ob
ihr getestet genesen oder geimpft seit
und von da aus hatten sie zumindest
einigermaßen gewissheit können denn die
unternehmen trotzdem noch sagen wir
möchten aber hier nur 3g nee das geht
nicht das ist ziemlich eindeutig
schlicht und ergreifend die grundlage
dafür her weg ist die ist explizit
gestrichen die steht wiederum um 28 b
und die wird ersatzlos fallen
doch was ist mit masken muss ich hier
sitze ich jetzt auch ohne maske im
großraumbüro
ja also das ist übrigens auch noch mal
interessanter punkt der auch noch
relativ offen ist es gibt jetzt die
möglichkeit für unternehmen also sie
können natürlich vieles freiwillig tun
bis oft 3g aber sie können natürlich
auch die leute in home office selber
weiterarbeiten lassen hindert sie ja
keiner dran es gibt auch die möglichkeit
dass die masken bereitstellen oder auch
tests bereitstellen aber die mitarbeiter
sind eben nicht mehr verpflichtet die
anzunehmen bei den masken
ist es interessant bisher war
tatsächlich eine regelung in der
arbeitsstättenverordnung
mehr drin so und jetzt sagt das
bundesarbeitsministerium spd geführt
naja das bedeutet aber nicht dass der
arbeitgeber nicht doch eine maske
pflicht verhängen kann schließlich ist
ja nur relativ geringe eingriffe in die
persönlichkeitsrechte so und stehe da
war ich drin steht nicht mehr explizit
drin ja könnte mir auch vorstellen dass
genau das dann für er sagt und dass ich
dann mitarbeitern
sagen na ja also meine ich mich nicht
richtig
[Musik]
das glaube ich auch da ist das
konfliktpotenzial echt hoch das glaube
ich auch ja also das ist ein bereich der
lustigerweise so ein bisschen links
liegen geblieben ist in der öffentlichen
diskussion den ich aber sehr wichtig
finde weil sie einfach mal 40 millionen
leute in deutschland beschäftigen wird
sind dann 40 millionen beschäftigte die
wir haben ja und ich kann auch sagen bei
den arbeitgebern und dann natürlich auch
gewerkschaften ist das natürlich ein
riesenthema und ich hatte gestern auch
kontakt zu hören wurde joachim mutter
aus der grundsatzabteilung recht von der
vereinigung der bayerischen wirtschaft
und von crm interessant was was der
berichtet hat auch was diese
unsicherheit und auch diese
auseinandersetzung bei den unternehmen
jetzt in den letzten tagen führen
eindruck hinterlassen hat und er sagte
aus sicht der arbeitgeber wäre viel
wichtiger längerfristige
planungssicherheit zu haben anstatt in
der woche vor dem schillernden freedom
day 3 kehrtwendungen in der einschätzung
zur anschließend gültigen rechtslage
vollziehen zu müssen das war nicht schön
zusammengefasst weil bis gestern auch
tatsächlich vieles relativ unklar noch
ware also insbesondere mehr gehört bei
der masken pflicht wie gesagt kann man
so oder so sehen
3 gg wird definitiv nicht mehr geben und
bei der home office schlicht könnte ich
mir auch vorstellen dass das für unmut
sorgt und ist daneben zu neuen
reibereien kommt es war natürlich
insofern einfacher jetzt für die
mitarbeiter dass wie es bisher war klar
na ja aber das ist im moment die lage
zum infektionsschutzgesetz vielleicht
noch letztes wir haben heute die lesung
im bundestag am freitag ist es im
bundesrat und dann ist wahrscheinlich
auch schon ab samstag in kraft wir haben
donnerstag noch mal ein treffen mit den
ministerpräsidenten
und der bundesregierung bin gespannt was
da noch irgendwie was rauskommt aber im
infektionsschutzgesetz selber wird sich
wohl nichts ändern
jedenfalls auf dieser ebene nicht weil
es einfach schlicht ich gehe also die
länder haben da wenig zu sagen
genau also vermutlich nichts mehr ändern
wird sich auch im laufe der woche bei
den vorschlägen im
infektionsschutzgesetz im 9 zum thema
genesen und geimpft nachweise denn da
ändert sich auch etwas und zwar wenig
überraschend für alle regelmäßigen
hörerinnen und hörer erst mal auf der
formal juristischen ebene denn die
definition von geimpft und genesen wird
wieder abgezogen vom rk ii und vom
paul-ehrlich-institut das wird jetzt
künftig im infektionsschutzgesetz
definiert wir hatten das thema ja in den
vergangenen wochen mehrfach da gab es
eine doppelte verweisung erst in die
kurve 19 schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmen
verordnung der bundesregierung und die
hat dann weiter delegiert und das rk ii
und das paul-ehrlich-institut konnten
per der veröffentlichung auf ihrer
webseite dann plötzlich
irritierenderweise bestimmen wer geht
denn jetzt eigentlich als geimpft und
wer gilt als genießen das wird jetzt
rück geändert aus naheliegenden gründen
das verstehe ich ja relativ evident
gegen den wesentlichkeit grundsatz
nachdem der gesetzgeber wesentliche
entscheidungen selber treffen muss aber
das ist nicht alles formaljuristisch
schön und wir freuen uns sehr so zu
sagen da lacht das juristinnen herz aber
ab dem 30 september ändert sich auch in
der sache direkt mal was und zwar
ändert sich wenn man als geimpft gilt ab
dem 30 09 gilt man nämlich nur noch dann
als geimpft wenn man drei einzel
impfungen erhalten hat also auf deutsch
gesagt wenn man gepustet ist und wenn
die dritte im funk mindestens drei
monate nach der zweiten impfung erfolgt
ist es reichen also nicht mehr wie
bisher zwei impfungen aus das ist jetzt
nicht total überraschend dass das
passiert und es ist auch noch recht
lange hin weil wie gesagt erst ab dem 30
aber es steht jetzt immerhin schon im
gesetz es wird ausnahmen geben es sollen
weiterhin zwei impfdosen ausreichen wenn
man zum beispiel nachweisen kann dass
man antikörper gebildet hat oder wenn
man vor oder nach der zweiten impfung
corona hatte also quasi genesen ist und
das per pcr test nachweisen kann und 28
tage zeit vergangen sind es wird auch
interessant übrigens nicht zum ersten
mal der antikörpern ist verärgert da
hatten wir bisher gar nicht hat die
bundesregierung immer oder die politik
generell komplett ignoriert übrigens
auch anders als andere länder aber jetzt
ist erstmal drin genau es ändert sich
dagegen nichts was vielleicht viele
geholfen hatten am genesenen status
werden wir erinnern uns den hatte das
lka mehr oder weniger zumindest ohne
öffentliche kommunikation geändert von
sechs monaten auf drei monate das heißt
man galt plötzlich nur noch drei monate
als genesen und das bleibt auch so also
es gilt weiterhin dass man erst 28 tage
nach der genesung und dann bis maximal
90 tage als genesen gilt das ist also
weiterhin eine abweichung von dem was eu
weit gilt da gelten eigentlich die die
180 tage also sechs monate ja auch das
muss man mal deutlich sagen da geht
deutschen schon einen sonderweg der
berühmte sonderweg genau also die
bundesregierung kann das auch weiterhin
abweichend alles regeln aber das steht
jetzt eben auch künftig im gesetz dann
bitte mit angemessenen übergangsfristen
wenn das war ja eben damit ihr januar so
dass plötzlich irgendwie von samstag auf
sonntag sich das auf dem setzt auf den
webseiten von rk ii und paul ehrlich
institut geändert hatte und plötzlich
waren menschen die nicht mehr genießen
die damit noch für monate kalkuliert
hatten also das wird sich jetzt
verändern in der sache bleibt aber dabei
nur noch drei monate gelesenen status
ausnahme ist für die einreise da bleibt
es beim vollständigen impfschutz das
fand ich auch noch relativ wichtig wenn
seit der zweiten impfung noch keine neun
monate vergangen sind das heißt es ist
jetzt nicht so dass man plötzlich nicht
mehr rein darf nach deutschland weil man
keine booster impfung hat da gilt es
weiterhin für neun monate auch irgendwie
eine merkwürdige ausnahmeregelung auch
wenn es dafür bestimmt irgendwie gute
gründe gibt auch wichtig das ist
vielleicht bisher auch noch keinem so
richtig aufgefallen es stehen jetzt die
selbsttests im infektionsschutzgesetz
drin also sieht alles danach aus dass
wohl die kostenlosen bürger tests
relativ zeitnah wieder abgeschafft
werden sollen außer eben für
beschäftigte im gesundheits
einrichtungen oder für schüler innen
klar oder wenn man natürlich kroner
symptome aufweist dafür gelten aber
andererseits daneben künftig auch selbst
tests unter aufsicht als ist sozusagen
man kann dann also für 2g oder 3g wenn
das in hotspots weiterhin verhängt
werden sollte sich vor ort testen wenn
da jemand zuschaut also keine ahnung
wenn man den weg gehen will oder so dann
dann kann der der kneipe sich das
anschauen dann gilt aber natürlich
dieser negative selbst heißt nur für den
zugang zu dieser kneipe also man kann
halt natürlich nicht mit einem
selbsttest loslaufen denen man irgendwie
zu hause gemacht hat oder vor kneipen
gemacht hat und dann durch noch durch
die stadt ziehen und sagen guck ich hab
doch von selbst gemacht bin mega die
zuwandern ein so funktioniert natürlich
nicht weil das wäre ja nur kontrolliere
fand ich interessant steht für super
interessant und gut dass du das einfach
mal so deutlich sagt weil auch da hatte
ich echt den eindruck also dass sich die
öffentliche diskussion wirklich einen
völlig falschen themen aufhängt weil
gerade das mit diesen bürger test das
wird noch interessant werden nicht
absolut genau also dass das geht auch
alles im moment so unter und und das war
uns heute wirklich auch sehr wichtig
deshalb machen wir das auch so
ausführlich dass wir so ein paar dinge
einfach mal versuchen geradezurücken
also dieses ganze geplapper von freedom
day und so das ist halt alles nicht halb
so wird nicht halb so heiß gegessen wie
es gekocht wird wie man so schön sagt ja
und da ist viel politik auch eben der
beine und
aber auch auf der anderen seite das
unvermögen sich selber zu verkaufen also
das mit blick auf die spd zum beispiel
um das was man da nie geschafft hat weil
ich steht dazu ein bisschen indem ich da
aber gut genau aussieht so nach außen
eigentlich alles so aus als hätte die
fdp sich in allen belangen so
durchgesetzt und weil der ball im
basisschutz so wenige instrumente
vorhanden sind tatsache ist aber
eigentlich das ja zumindest in sehr
vielen gebieten die hotspot regelungen
heute noch locker verhängt werden
könnten ich weiß wovon ich spreche ich
wohne in köln wir haben ja hier karneval
gefeiert von daher sind die insolvenzen
natürlich auch dementsprechend und von
daher finde ich eigentlich auch dass die
spd sich da schon etwas unter wert
verkauft denn da sind durchaus sehr
viele instrumente noch vorhanden wenn es
in gebieten nicht gut läuft
[Musik]
nun gut jetzt sind wir aber tatsächlich
bei der impfpflicht genau wie wollten
wir euch einmal kurz vorstellen die
impfpflicht ist diese woche dann jetzt
endlich mal im bundestag das kommt einem
irgendwie ein bisschen retro auf der
einen seite irgendwie diskutieren wir
hier über lockerungen aller orten und
das kommt einem irgendwie mieses timing
vor und kommunikativ relativ schwierig
auf der anderen seite die zahlen steigen
natürlich drastisch wieder an also die
inzidenz ist heute so hoch wie nie zuvor
mit
1607 immer noch sterben natürlich
relativ viele menschen an oder mit
corona und natürlich gibt es auch immer
noch lankowitz die impfquoten sind auch
immer noch schlecht in deutschland also
stand heute haben immer noch nur 76 5
prozent der bevölkerung ist ein
mindestens eine impfung
75,7 sind vollständig gegen kuwait 19
gmt vollständig geimpft ist wie wir
gerade noch mal gelernt haben ja derzeit
zweifach geimpft und noch nicht mal 60
prozent sind gebucht hat das sind diese
zahlen aber
es geht eigentlich gar nicht so sehr um
den aktuellen stand sondern die
impfpflicht das wird immer begründet mit
der situation die im herbst winter
kommen wird denn eigentlich hat niemand
ernsthafte zweifel daran dass die
nächste corona welle kommen wird auf der
anderen seite hat halt kein bock auf den
ernsthaften dritten corona winter mit so
krassen grundrechts einschränkungen wie
wir sie in den letzten zwei jahren
erlebt haben das heißt die also der
gedanke hinter allen impfpflicht planen
ist natürlich immer dass jetzt die leute
vorsorgen wollen damit mit der mit der
neuen mit neuen varianten oder auch zum
beispiel mit der alten variante es gibt
ja auch relativ viele wissenschaftler
innen die davon ausgehen dass die delta
variante noch mal zurückkommen wird dass
das virus dann nicht noch mal
gefährlicher wird und deshalb eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems droht
da gibt es jetzt fünf anträge die über
die im bundestag gesprochen werden wird
leider von sin fraktionsübergreifend wir
wissen ja die die bundesregierung selbst
hat da nichts vorgelegt sehr zum unmut
von cdu und csu
vielleicht beginnen wir einmal damit
dass es ein lustiger weise zwei anträge
gibt etwas nicht zu beschließen nämlich
eine impfpflicht ist es passiert jetzt
auch nicht alle tage das explizite
anträge gibt nichts zu beschließen das
ist einmal natürlich der afg entwurf
wollen natürlich keine impfpflicht haben
da ist die begründung auch naja er
rechtlich schwach sozusagen etwas ernst
zu nehmen da ist der entwurf von
wolfgang kubicki der hat ja auch damit
schon relativ viel öffentliche
aufmerksamkeit erzielt das steht aber
zum beispiel auch gregor gysi dahinter
das war mir gar nicht so klar auch da
gibt es eben einen einen
fraktionsübergreifenden
entwurf die impfbereitschaft ohne
allgemeine impfpflicht zu erhöhen das
argument liegt auf der hand so ein
bisschen es gibt so viele offene fragen
also eigentlich kann man eben nicht
nachweisen dass die impfung notwendig
ist vielleicht ist sie auf der anderen
seite sogar schädlich und wesentliches
argument ist eben immer das die
wirksamkeit der impfstoffe geringer ist
als zum beispiel bei masern also bei
masern wo es ja eine impfpflicht gibt
da haben wir eine wirksamkeit von
ungefähr 98 bis 99 prozent und dann ist
das argument eben wir können ja selbst
wenn wir die pflicht hätten das virus
gar nicht ausrotten und deshalb könne
deutschland auch keine impfpflicht
beschließen so lange man gar nicht weiß
wie häufig dann geimpft werden muss wie
wirksam die impfstoffe sind also long
story short zu viele fragen als dass
mein verfassungsgemäß eine impfpflicht
beschließen könnte so und es gibt aber
nicht nur an dränge dinge nicht zu
beschließen sondern es gibt vor allem
einen antrag der bei dem es im moment so
aussieht als ob der wohl die besten
chancen hat er wird derzeit von 233
abgeordneten unterstützt unter anderem
von olaf scholz zum beispiel von
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach aber
natürlich nicht in seiner funktion als
gesundheitsminister sondern nur als
abgeordneter aber auch ford annalena
baerbock oder janosch dahmen von den
grünen und natürlich von dirk wiese von
der spd das ist die impfpflicht ab 18
also praktisch komplette impfpflicht für
alle erwachsenen und zwar mit sofortiger
wirkung wie wird das begründet natürlich
mit den stark gestiegenen instanzen und
mit der sehr sehr hohen ansteckung von
omikron
natürlich damit dass also auch omikron
auch wenn es milder verläuft alle einer
allein deshalb weil so viele menschen
sich anstecken das gesundheitssystem
trotzdem wieder überlastet werden kann
und auf der anderen seite dass es eben
sehr sichere hoch wirksame impfstoffe
gibt die nicht nur die person selber
schützen sondern die auch gegen omikron
schützen vor allem auch nach der dritten
impfung und natürlich auch allgemein
schützen ich glaube es ist jetzt
hinreichend bekannt dass eine
ausreichend hohe impfquoten in allen
altersgruppen die weiterverbreitung des
virus einfach eindämmen würde so und
damit argumentieren die auch und sagen
wir möchten eben nicht wie eine andere
gruppe von abgeordneten nun pflicht über
50 haben sondern eine impfpflicht über
18 auch eben deshalb weil man damit die
entstehung von weiteren virusvarianten
vermindert so also was schlagen die
genau vor alle schlagen übrigens vorerst
mal noch die impfkampagnen hochzufahren
und so weiter in diesem vorschlag heißt
es dann auch alle erwachsenen sollen
persönlich kontaktiert werden von der
krankenversicherung und über
beratungsmöglichkeiten
informiert werden so das ist im prinzip
allen vorgesehen und dann soll es im
zweiten schritt diese allgemeine
impfpflicht geben für personen über 18
das bedeutet allgemeine impfpflicht
heißt man muss einen impf oder genesene
nachweis vorlegen können also auf
anforderung vorlegen können es sind
immer ausnahmen vorgesehen für menschen
die sich aus medizinischen gründen nicht
impfen lassen können klar und für
schwangere jeweils im ersten drittel der
schwangerschaft das soll alles auch
relativ häufig evaluiert werden nämlich
viertel jährlich und erstmal sowieso nur
gelten bis 31 12 und 20 23 also dass wir
dann maximal ein jahr und drei monate
roundabout und was natürlich immer
wichtig ist wie würde denn so eine
impfpflicht überhaupt umgesetzt also
hier die einzige kontrollmöglichkeit
während die krankenkassen
da soll es an diesem vorschlag also es
stellt sich hier auch das ist ja die
freuen sich bestimmt totalen und glaube
ich auch aber ich glaube das muss man
schon noch immer wieder betonen es soll
nicht so sein dass die polizei oder
irgendwelche ordnungsbehörden dann in
häuser rennen und menschen nadeln in die
arme jetzt macht gerne hätten und es
gibt auch keine
keine zwangsmittel die vorgesehen werden
mit ausnahme von zwangsgeld also auf
deutsch gesagt bußgeldern und wenn die
uneinbringlich wären soll es auch
explizit keine ersatz zwangshaft oder
oder gar erzwingungshaft geben das ist
alles nicht vorgesehen das heißt solche
umsetzungsmöglichkeiten an die denkt
keiner
dass die argumentieren im prinzip damit
dass sie sagen wenn wir eine impfpflicht
sowie das andere entwürfe vorsehen erst
ab dem herbst aktivieren würden dann
würde das einfach aus zeitlichen gründen
nicht mehr ausreichend denn wie gesagt
es geht ja eben wir müssen uns wappnen
gegen diese welt die im herbst kommen
wird das heißt ab september aller
spitzen sword ober und man braucht ja
drei impfungen und selbst wenn man die
ersten beiden impfungen mit einer
taktung von zwei wochen kriegen würde
müsste man die halt spätestens im juni
bekommen damit man im september geimpft
wäre das heißt die argumentieren damit
wir können jetzt nicht noch irgendwie
abwarten bis zum herbst sondern wir
müssen sofort damit loslegen und
vielleicht das auch noch mal an dieser
stelle zu sagen wie der zeitliche ablauf
ist wir haben wir jetzt die erste lesung
die zweite und dritte lesung ist
voraussichtlich für den 7 april geplant
also wir reden jetzt wir kommen jetzt in
der tat in die heiße phase dessen das
heißt mitte april könnte sozusagen die
sache auch schon entschieden sein
hier also quasi das ist der breiteste
mit impfungen ab 18 genau und zwar auch
sofort zu beschließende im pflicht zu
sagen dann gibt es noch im zweiten
entwurf der ist schon etwas vermitteln
da ist zum beispiel cem özdemir
unterstützt den aber auch kevin kühn hat
also der spd generalsekretär einer der
relativ bekannten initiatoren ist der
and roll man von der fdp und da muss man
sagen dass der jetzt wohl da können wir
euch auch noch mal einen relativ
spannenden artikel von helene bobrowski
tja auch hier manchmal den podcast
mitmacht verlinken von gestern der ist
der der geht wohl von seiner eigenen von
seinem eigenen entwurf jetzt
mittlerweile immer weiter weg wie
übrigens weiter teile der fdp die jetzt
eigentlich schon sagen naja eine
impfpflicht wollen wir eigentlich doch
gar nicht mehr dieser entwurf sagt aber
im grundsatz ebenfalls erst noch mal
persönlich kontaktieren alle erwachsenen
und so weiter aber der unterschied ist
dann eben dass man ab dem 15
falls das nach der infektion slave und
im stand der impfkampagne erforderlich
wäre den bundestag schon heute in die
lage versetzen würde durch beschluss
festzulegen dass person über 50 geimpft
oder gewesen sein müssen so also das
sind dann direkt zwei voraussetzungen
die der allgemeine 11 die allgemeine
impfpflicht sozusagen die ich hätte
erstes mal das betrifft nur menschen
soll nur menschen über 50 betreffen und
zweitens ist soll auch jetzt noch nicht
aktiviert werden sondern es würde eben
dann jetzt nur ins gesetz
reingeschrieben na ja wir gucken dann
mal wie es aussieht unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen die auch noch nicht sehr
genau definiert das muss man sagen soll
der bundestag dann sehr schnell agieren
können und ab dem 15 9 also mitte
september würde das dann in kraft
gesetzt werden wir haben es gerade schon
gehört die verfechter ihnen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht sagen das ist
natürlich alles viel zu spät weil wenn
ich dann die leute erst verpflichtete
sich impfen zu lassen dann ist es ist
man halt mitte dezember und dann sind
wir schon in der welle wieder mittendrin
auch da durchsetzung mit keine
zwangsmittel es gebe nur ein zwangsgeld
und so weiter die begründung liegt auf
der hand ab 50 jahre ist natürlich ein
milderes mittel weil logischerweise viel
weniger menschen dann sich impfen lassen
müssten und diese gruppe beruft sich
auch stark auf den ethikrat der ethikrat
zum beispiel auch gesagt dass so im
vergleich zu einer undifferenzierten
impfpflicht für alle erwachsenen ein
milderes mittel natürlich irgendwie ja
ethisch besser vertretbar wäre
verfassungsmäßig ist es klar auch ein
näher liegend ein milderes mittel und
begründet wird es natürlich alles darum
dass über 50-jährige schwerere verläufe
haben das wissen wir ja also wir
erinnern uns alle an den an den start
der pandemie als wir ja auch nach dem
alter dann quasi priorisiert haben so
und dann gibt es noch den das sogenannte
im vorsorge setzte der cdu csu fraktion
also die haben auch als fraktion einen
als oppositionsfraktion einen vorschlag
vorgelegt
der ist gar nicht so weit entfernt von
dem dem ich gerade vorgestellt hatte
auch da soll es dann darum gehen dass
der bundestag in die lage versetzt
werden würde sehr schnell zu entscheiden
dass ab herbst ein impfstoff muss
vierter immer drin greifen muss also und
dieser mechanismus soll dann vorsehen
dass eine gestufte impfpflicht in kraft
treten würde also erstmal quasi für die
über 60 jährigen dann für die über
50-jährigen und natürlich für bestimmte
berufsgruppen also keine ahnung kita
mitarbeitende und so weiter das ist auch
noch relativ schwammig da steht dann so
was drin wie es kommt aber auch eine
darüber hinausgehende impfpflicht in
betracht also auch da muss man sagen
noch nicht so richtig aus definiert die
voraussetzungen wann der bundestag das
eigentlich beschließen soll sind auch
noch nicht wirklich da drin da heißt
natürlich irgendwie bei neuen varianten
funktions system das gesundheitssystem
in gefahr funktionsfähigkeit ballon aber
so richtig definiert ist das auch noch
nicht klar sind die fünf anträge die auf
dem tisch liegen habe es gerade schon
gesagt die fdp wird da immer na ja also
um genau das vielleicht noch einmal
aufzugreifen
das alles spielt ist natürlich ein
spiegel der gesellschaftlichen debatte
und dem was wir jetzt gerade sehen mit
der einführung der einrichtungs
bezogenen impfpflicht wir haben schon
darüber gesprochen die gilt übrigens die
scharf gestellt seit gestern also seit
dienstag den 15 geht die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht haben wir hier auch
schon weitreichend diskutiert auch da
wieder eine unglaubliche politische
aufregung zwischendrin ja die keiner hat
richtig kommen sehen auch da wieder die
vorwürfe schlecht vorbereitet zu viele
unbestimmte rechtsbegriffe zu wenig
leitplanken für die gesundheitsämter
aber sie ist jetzt da viele bundesländer
haben auch gesagt sie räumen sehr
großzügige
übergangsfristen für die mitarbeiter ein
ich bin wirklich gespannt ich meine das
muss man ja sagen das eine hängt an dem
anderen dran ja also so sehr wie der
gegenwind da jetzt gekommen ist auch
ganz aus ganz unterschiedlichen ecken ja
auch viel aus dem medizinbereich wir
hatten hier auch wo ich den
eindrückliche appell von der einen
krankenhaus leiterin den ich vor ein
paar wochen mal vorgelesen habe da wo
einfach klar ist also wenn man das dann
tatsächlich an der front quasi
durchsetzen muss in den einrichtungen
selber sieht die welt dann tatsächlich
doch anders aus also ich bin echt
gespannt wie die debatte jetzt
weitergeht mit der impfpflicht ich auch
wobei ich halt immer schon findet das
sind immer noch zwei sehr
unterschiedliche dinge die jetzt weniger
weil weil eben bei einer bei einer
einrichtung bezogenen impfpflicht
einfach nur eine gruppe rausgenommen
wird das ist ja aus meiner sicht evident
keine diskriminierung denn es gibt gute
gründe diese gruppe rauszunehmen aber
bei der umsetzung ist natürlich die ist
natürlich überhaupt nicht vergleichbar
denn auf der einen seite kann ich halt
sagen platz werde ich dann kontrolliert
und ich darf dann meinen arbeitsplatz
schlicht nicht mehr betreten wenn ich
eine ungeimpfte keine ahnung pflegerin
bin und auf der anderen seite wenn man
für eine allgemeine impfpflicht spricht
dann gibt es eben keine kontrolle am
arbeitsplatz oder so alt diese dinge
sind ja angedacht wurden aber verworfen
worden das ist alles nicht geplant nun
also die umsetzung kann man überhaupt
nicht vergleichen finde ich von daher
finde ich eigentlich immer diesen satz
schwierig naja dass das eine folgt aus
dem anderen oder ist die konsequenz ist
anderen das sehe ich schon noch
irgendwie echt anlass und echt
differenziert ich habe das gefühl dass
es quasi seit dem syrischen angriff auf
die
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht
entscheide ich muss mich übrigens echt
entschuldigen kapazität so ganz
unbewusst auch viel so kampf vokabular
drin ist werde ich natürlich eigentlich
überhaupt nicht das
werde ich mich jetzt hin und wieder mal
das möchte ich natürlich alles
relativieren also seitdem zu löschen
ja wie formuliert man sich der kritik
dass jetzt allerdings dann auch zu wenig
an der einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
also ich glaube schon dass man da schon
auch so ein umdenken
gesehen hat in vier erstaunlich vielen
teilen der bevölkerung also ganz
schlicht nach dem motto wenn es schon
schwierig ist in dieser gruppe des
einzuführen wie soll man es dann auf
anderer ebene machen also alles was ich
höre ich bin auch wirklich gespannt wie
sich das weiter entwickelt der nach sehr
gespannt wie die länder das überhaupt
durchziehen werden damit der anerzogenen
impfpflicht also unabhängig von von
gewährten großzügige übergangsfristen
kenne ich auch persönlich zum beispiel
pfleger die sagen ich gehe einfach nicht
davon aus dass das irgendwer
kontrollieren wird das wird dann
gemeldet ans gesundheitsamt aber ich
glaube nicht dass da irgendwie was
passieren wird oder dass ich tatsächlich
meinen job nicht mehr auslauf also die
sind da schon wirklich sehr sehr
entspannt und dann kann man sich aber
auch sparen ehrlich gesagt genau richtig
ja das sehe ich auch so man darf
gespannt bleiben wir wollten euch noch
nur einmal die entwürfe vorstellen die
jetzt in dieser ab dieser woche zur
abstimmung stehen damit ihr auch wisst
darüber gesprochen vielleicht noch ein
letzter hinweis bis jetzt hat eben keine
entwürfe eine mehrheit als nur eine
einfache mehrheit notwendig aber
immerhin die
muss erreicht werden man könnte sich
dann vorstellen dass tatsächlich
allianzen geschmiedet werden und dann
die die fraktion da oder sich die gruppe
muss man sagen mit der impfpflicht über
18 fusioniert wird mit der über 50
natürlich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
schlecht dass ausgerechnet derjenige der
die diesen antrag vor allen dingen
eingebracht hat sich dass sie jetzt
wieder anders überlegt hat aber das sind
ja nun auch andere leute drin die
vielleicht auch ein interesse daran
haben dass dann weiter zu treiben es
könnte ja auch durchaus einen
zusammenschluss geben zwischen spd und
union das wird jetzt wohl auch eher
nicht mehr für so unwahrscheinlich
gehalten dass er eben die union mit geht
da müsste die spd dann vielleicht eine
kleine kröte schlucken weil die union
eben in ihrem vorschlag das sogenannte
emv register drin hat also die wollen
auf grundlage der der
steueridentifikationsnummer erst mal so
ein bisschen ordnung schaffen wer ist
denn eigentlich in welcher altersgruppe
geimpft und so weiter weil das eben auch
die voraussetzung dafür wäre dass man
dann irgendwann am ende sagen kann wie
sieht es denn aus mit den pfoten und
wann könnten wir den mechanismus
überhaupt mal scharf schalten da weint
die fdp natürlich und sagt das möchten
wir auf gar keinen fall so nimmt
register die ist spd könnte das wohl
mitgehen und da passt wäre wohl auch
noch eine möglichkeit das dann spd und
union sich zusammenschließen um es ohne
die ohne die fdp machen zu können okay
so jetzt schließen aber diesen ganzen
komplex mal ab genug über corona gerät
ich möchte diesen ganzen block nicht
beenden ohne nochmal andrea kießling
gedankt zu haben das ist rechts zu
zentren von der universität bochum die
er auch schon seit langer langer zeit
immer wieder als sachverständige zur
verfügung steht nicht nur für mich oder
unseren podcast sehen wir sie ja auch
schon öfter sondern natürlich auch für
den bundestag war montag wieder im
gesundheitsausschuss und hat der rede
und antwort gestanden und ehrlich gesagt
habe ich sie gestern eben auch mehrfach
belämmert mit konkreten fragen und über
waren sich geduldig und sehr
kenntnisreich also deswegen herzlichen
dank an sie liebe frau kießling
das hat uns hier wirklich sehr
weitergeholfen
so und jetzt kommen wir zu den
nachträgen
können und zwar erst ein wenig dann doch
noch die ukraine krise sozusagen
russland verlässt offenbar tatsächlich
den europarat genau wir hatten es auch
schon vor ein paar wochen da ging es
darum dass russland erst mal nur
suspendiert werden sollte von dieser
organisation die ja immerhin 4 47
mitglieder hat mitgliedstaaten hat die
eine sehr ehrwürdige institution ist wo
man auch das gefühl hatte dass da das
ganze einem
menschenrechtlichen rahmen gibt also
auch dass russland oder länder wie
russland oder ehrlich gesagt auch die
türkei der immer wieder auch so ein
bisschen zur räson gebracht werden
können das ist bei russland einfach
vorbei also russland tritt aus dem
europarat aus und kommt damit einem
ausschluss zuvor
und wichtig daran zu wissen ist nur wer
mitglied im europarat ist und da fällt
auch der gerichtsbarkeit des
europäischen gerichtshofs für
menschenrechte das heißt die ganzen
künftigen verfahren zur crème auch zum
zur ukraine generell zu den vielen
vielen menschenrechtsverletzungen in
russland
wird es künftig nicht mehr geben man
kann sich natürlich jetzt schon fragen
wie groß der unterschied zu vorher ist
in russland hat sich jan egmr urteile
schon bisher nicht sehr gebunden gefühlt
aber jetzt ist es dann quasi offiziell
sie sind sie fallen dann nicht mehr
runter
und nun kommen wir zu dir du hast auch
noch ein nachtrag zu dem afc rechter
jens maier genau den gefühlt 48 nachtrag
wir wollten es euch aber trotzdem kurz
mitbringen wir haben es euch erzählt chf
die richter also jens meier ist ein
ehemaliger fdp bundestagsabgeordneter
der zum zwischenzeitlicher zumindest
offiziell aufgelösten flügel gehörte
meyer kommt aus sachsen und wird im
sächsischen verfassungsschutz bericht
als rechtsextrem mist bezeichnet ist
auch durch durchaus häufiger mal
ausfällig geworden in seiner zeit im
bundestag also zwischen 17 und 22 21
jetzt hat er aber kein bundestagsmandat
mehr bekommen und er möchte in seinen
ursprungsort zurück und das ist dass
richter amt und jetzt ist jens maier
tatsächlich erstmals zurück bei gericht
nämlich am amtsgericht dippoldiswalde
ich muss mir immer diesen namen
aufschreiben ich kann mir diesen
ortsnamen nicht merken liebe einwohner
innen von dippoldiswalde wenn ihr eine
wie eine eine eselsbrücke für mich habt
schickt sie uns bitte sehr sehr gerne
das war eigentlich so nicht so ganz
gedacht nachdem jens maier seinen antrag
gestellt hätte dass er zurück in den
richter dienst wollte gab es erstmal
eine ziemliche öffentliche aufregung
grundsätzlich hat man als beamter
natürlich eine rückkehr anspruch wenn
man kann zb bundestagsmandat mehr hat
und irgendwie abgeordnet ist aber auch
dem justizministerium in sachsen wurde
dann angesichts zunehmender öffentlicher
empörung wohl auch mal irgendwann klar
dass man sich das wohl doch mal
anschauen sollte wenn da so ein ich sage
es jetzt mal offen so wie es ist ein
verfassungsfeind wieder zurück auf die
richterbank möchte und das dauerte dann
alles ein bisschen der hatte im dezember
beantragt dass er wieder zurück kann im
februar hat dann hat dann das
justizministerium in sachsen einen
antrag auf versetzung von jens maier in
den ruhestand gestellt und einen
eilantrag gestellt denn jens maier
vorläufig die führung der amtsgeschäfte
zu untersagen und letzteres ist jetzt
erst mal schief gegangen das mit dem
eilantrag nämlich also über den
eilantrag wurde am dienst gerecht in
sachsen am landgericht sachsen nicht
entschieden bisher da war wohl auch das
justizministerium nicht so richtig
amüsiert das konnte man der
pressemitteilung vom montag sehr
deutlich entnehmen und das heißt eben
dass jens maier sein dienst jetzt
angetreten hat denn der ist jetzt am
amtsgericht dippoldiswalde eben wieder
losgegangen ab dem 14 märz also am
letzten montag das heißt dann musste er
da auch antreten und zwar als
zivilrichter also er ist da jetzt mal
hat man zivilrechtlich ist dezernat mit
schwerpunkt miete und verkehrsunfälle in
geringem umfang wohl auch nachlasssachen
das heißt er hat ja jetzt erst mal
angefangen zu arbeiten ist vielleicht
nicht so erfreulich direkt am ersten tag
wurde aber dann von seiner vorgesetzten
am landgericht dresden also dass das
ag.de poldis wald gehört zum lg bezirk
dresden ein disziplinarverfahren
eingeleitet
das ging natürlich auch erst als jetzt
mal wieder im dienst war denn man kann
natürlich nur ein disziplinarverfahren
gegen beamte einleiten die auch im
dienst sind und nicht die irgendwo im
bundestag sitzen und da hieß es dann
eben jetzt dass es den verdacht gibt
dass jens maier seine dienstpflichten
zur verfassungstreue zur politischen
mäßigung und zu achtungs und
vertrauenswürdigen verhalten verletzt
hat das heißt es laufen jetzt ein
disziplinarverfahren am landgericht
dresden es läuft ein antrag auf
versetzung in den ruhestand und das
eilverfahren dass er gar nicht vorläufig
seine amtsgeschäfte
durchführen darf am landgericht leipzig
und die grünen in sachsen haben wohl
auch immer noch die sogenannte richter
anklage auf den schirm also das ist dann
eben die möglichkeit dass der sächsische
landtag mit zwei drittel mehrheit einen
antrag auf entlassung von jens maier
stellen könnte das ist bisher noch nie
passiert in deutschland und deswegen
haben die grünen in sachsen professor
christoph möllers mit einem gutachten
dazu beauftragt das dürfte wohl relativ
weit kommen und dann ist darf man
gespannt sein ob diese richter anklage
da irgendwie möglich sein könnte laut
dem gutachten und ob dann der landtag in
sachsen die richter anklage auch taten
nicht ein also ganz viel zu tun
rechtlich video gerüstet vielleicht eine
kurze frage noch das dienst gericht noch
nicht entschieden hatte und deswegen
erstmal sein posten einnehmen konnte war
es jetzt böser wille sabotage oder liegt
es einfach schlicht und ergreifend auch
daran dass gewisse fristen oder auch
anhörungen da also geleistet werden
mussten ich kenne mich mit mit
dienstrecht relativ wenig aus allerdings
muss man sagen dass normalerweise ist
schon eigentlich möglich sein müsste
binnen vier wochen eine entscheidung zu
treffen also es hieß auch so sehr
schmallippig nur aus prozessualen
gründen seitdem vergangen also mehr weiß
ich leider auch nicht ob da tatsächlich
irgendwelche fristen irgendwie gelaufen
sind oder so ich weiß es nicht genau
normalerweise sollte man schon annehmen
dass an dem landgericht irgendwie
innerhalb innerhalb von fünf wochen
vergehen kann mit fristen habe ich
natürlich quatsch erzählt ich meine das
meinte ich nicht sondern ich meinte
natürlich ob das verfahren das rechtlich
tatsächlich irgendwie der der gegenseite
natürlich die möglichkeit zur anhörung
gegeben werden musste und weiter und
dann akteneinsicht gefordert wurde oder
wie auch immer zahlreicher und die
akteneinsicht ist wohl gefordert der
jens meyer hat natürlich ein anwalt und
der hat jetzt akteneinsicht erst mal
angefordert also es kann sein ja auch
das einfach mal mit prozessualen gründen
aber es ist halt einfach schmallippig
und die haben sich dazu überhaupt nicht
geäußert ja gut oder auch nicht gut aber
es ist wie es ist also ihr könnt euch
das noch mal anhören wenn ihr möchtet
sozusagen worum geht es eigentlich warum
wäre jetzt mal ein problem ein
verfassungsfeind in den reihen der
justiz was haben wir primär gemacht in
der folge 192 vom 12 januar
[Musik]
ja und dann sind wir jetzt beim
gerechten urteil wie gesagt auch nicht
besonders launig aber folgerichtig und
auch gerecht gerecht aber buckle ab ein
gerechtes urteil vom bundesfinanzhof die
hna nicht alle tage genau und da kann
ich auch schon mal sagen da werden wir
nicht allzu tief in die details
einsteigen weil es natürlich immer noch
ein bisschen schwerer kost ist ja das
sind ja auch alles sehr kluge leute die
da sitzen aber man kann jetzt ehrlich
gesagt auch kommt nicht umhin zu sagen
jetzt hat auch der bundesfinanzhof
festgestellt bei comics geschäften
handelt es sich um eine strafbare zu
steuerhinterziehung das ist vielleicht
so mal die große überschrift unter der
ich das bei fassen möchte und da kommt
er dann doch reichlich spät wenn ich
kann ich mir diese kleine kritik auch
nicht vergreifen denn es ist wahrlich
nicht das erste bundesgericht das in
diese richtung geht der
bundesgerichtshof hat es schon im juli
20 21 klar gestellt dass das
rechtswidrige geschäfte waren die eben
dazu führten dass wenn man quasi die
steuer zurückgefordert hat es sich um
eine strafbare
steuerhinterziehung handelt so und
nun hat jedenfalls sozusagen der
bundesfinanzhof das ganze
flankiert und es ist auch deswegen so
bedauerlich dass das jetzt erst kommt im
jahr 2022 weil die rechtsprechung des
bundesfinanzhofes auch immer zur
rechtfertigung für solche geschäfte
herhalten musste ja und dann haben sie
jetzt auch noch mal deutlich gesagt
wurde zu unrecht da wurden wir falsch
verstanden das haben wir so nie gesagt
aber nichtsdestotrotz war auch die
kritik in den vergangenen jahren immer
laut dass man gesagt hat wie so
entscheidet der bundesfinanzhof nicht
mal also natürlich sind auch schwierigen
angedauert naja dieses urteil haben
wirklich alle lange gewartet und man
braucht natürlich auch immer die
entsprechenden fall aber ist also gar
nicht so wahnsinnig in die tiefe geben
das hatte natürlich auch alles um seine
gründe aber jedenfalls haben wir nun die
entscheidung des
bundesfinanzhofs und vielleicht erklärt
noch mal ganz kurz worum es ging geklagt
hatte ein us amerikanischer
pensionsfonds der eben eine
steuererstattung haben wollte und zwar
in höhe von 27 millionen euro
schnäppchen ja genau aber muss ich sagen
ich vielleicht hier sollte ich schon
immer innehalten bei dem us
amerikanischen pensionsfonds sind
eigentlich jetzt nicht die allergrößten
schweine am markt wenn ich es mal so
sagen war also will sagen ja in
pensionsfonds haben ihm viele kleiner
lehrer ihre erspart es ist aber erspart
es drin die wollen halt ihr geld für die
rente haben das ist ein normaler weise
das ist ein pensionsfonds eben macht und
auch solche
institutionellen anleger waren eben an
diesen comex geschäften beteiligt das
kann man vielleicht an dieser stelle
hier auch noch einmal deutlich sagen ja
waren natürlich viele viele
finanzinstitute die damit gemacht haben
vielleicht noch einmal ein wort der
irgendwas für geschäfte ging es da es
sind eben comex geschäfte sind
aktiengeschäfte mit wertpapiere die
jeweils kurz vor dem dividenden stichtag
eines unternehmens gehandelt werden und
zwar eben einmal mit dividende deswegen
kommt dividend und danone also ex
dividende da kommt der name her comex
und guter grundsatz war eben das
normalerweise bei solchen
transaktionen im steuern fällig wäre die
institutionelle investoren wieder
zurückfordern können aber natürlich nur
dann wenn sie sie auch gezahlt haben und
das hatte dieser us-pensionsfonds nicht
getan und hatte trotzdem die erstattung
bevor der clou sagen wir mal so bei
diesen comex geschäft ist alles ein
bisschen komplizierter weil wenn es die
ganze zeit immer nur in einer hand
gewesen wäre dann hätte man ja dass sich
sagen können naja kasse bezahlt hast du
nicht dann ist ja irgendwie kann sie
auch nicht
zurückfordern der charme an diesen
komplex geschäften ist ja dass er
mehrere leute verwickelt waren
institutionelle anleger die sozusagen
dass das hin und her gehandelt haben und
wo ihr dann immer einer behauptet hat
ich habe doch die steuer bezahlt
sozusagen und der andere weil er das
papier dann gekauft hat das
zurückfordern wollte weil wie gesagt
steuern von diesen institutionellen
anlegern nicht gezahlt werden müssen die
werden aber automatisch eingezogen und
dann das so ist der mechanismus kann man
sie sich eben zurückfordern und das war
das große paket und jetzt gab es
tatsächlich auch mal eine zeit an die
sich auch tatsächlich niemand mehr so
richtig erinnern wo es tatsächlich leute
gehabt die gesagt haben ja auch in
dieser konstellation gibt es eben die
möglichkeit dass zurückzufordern
weil man doch um wie wirtschaftlicher
eigentümer geworden ist und so weiter
und jetzt hat schon das finanzgericht
köln die eben die ersten waren die
diesen fall in der hand haben haben das
ins entschieden dass ich sich hierbei um
einen rechtlich unzulässigen versuch
handelt eine mehrfach eine mehrfache
erstattung einer nur einmalig
abgeführten steuern zu erreichen und das
hat die damals schon also der richter
damals schon gesagt das ist eine
kriminelle
glanzleistung gewesen und hat die klage
eben auch steuerrückerstattungen
abgewiesen auch da noch mal wie gesagt
es geht an ging eigentlich nur um die
forderung wir wollen die kohle zurück
haben das ist jetzt kein strafverfahren
gewesen sondern eigentlich nur der sehr
alltäglichen vorgang dieses ich habe
hier zu viel gezahlt ich möchte geld
zurückhaben und da auch schon da hat das
finanzgericht köln deutlich gemacht hier
gab es eine kriminelle
glanzleistung und der bfh hat sich
natürlich den weg bringen es begann er
hat sich jedenfalls in wedding nicht so
angeschlossen aber hat schon
festgestellt dass der psv hier kein
wirtschaftliches eigentum erworben hat
hier geht es nämlich um ein modellhaft
aufgelegtes gesamt vertrags konzept
nachdem der erwerber die wesentlich mit
dem aktienerwerb verbundenen rechte
wieder ausüben kann noch nach dieser
konstruktion soll er hat vielmehr nur
die funktion eine seine rechtsform in
den geschäftsablauf einzubringen also
quasi nur passiver teilnehmer er will
sagen es hat ihm geholfen das ebenfalls
vor war ja und deswegen die steuern
zurückfordern kann deswegen war der eben
da drin so also das wurde jetzt vom bfh
auch noch mal festgestellt wir sagen das
ist zutiefst gerecht auch wenn es jetzt
vielleicht sich gerade rechtliches
neuland beschreitet aber das ganze ist
natürlich vor allen dingen in dieser
ganzen strafrechtlichen dimension
interessant die jetzt ja auch bei weitem
noch nicht abgeschlossen ist wir hatten
das bgh-urteil im vergangenen juli aber
wichtige verfahren stehen noch aus wir
haben eine an den der hauptfiguren den
ehemaligen steueranwalt hamberger der
jetzt in deutschland im gefängnis sitzt
er war das jetzt ausgeliefert worden
genau in der schweiz im exil und dann
kam in auslieferungshaft saß da mehrere
monate auch und wurde jetzt vor ein paar
wochen tatsächlich ausgeliefert das
heißt man könnte dann demnächst auch
damit rechnen dass auch er sich in
wiesbaden vor allem strafgericht
verantworten muss das lg wiesbaden
meines erachtens auch schon terminiert
und das obwohl hanno berger keine
anwälte mehr hat die haben nämlich ihre
mandate niedergelegt genau also auch da
gibt es wirklich endlich verstrickungen
wir haben auch wirklich ein sehr sehr
intensiv schon über das gesprochen über
comics gesprochen wird es da noch mal
einen denken möchte kann diese folge
gerne sich nochmals zu gemüte führen so
aber damit wären wir doch jetzt am ende
ja und wir entschuldigen uns sehr dass
wir auch zum ende selbst im gerechten
urteil so schwere kost mitbringen es gab
einfach wenig zu lachen in der
vergangenen woche das muss man mal so
sagen ja dass wir geben uns sehr viel
mühe nächste woche wieder ein
gerechteres und vielleicht auch
schöneres urteile zu gut genau und ich
meine wir hier in deutschland wirklich
echt noch gut ich also wie gesagt noch
mal das bedauern dass wir uns jetzt mit
der ukraine nicht beschäftigen konnten
aber ich möchte vielleicht noch einen
hinweis geben es gab wirklich einen ganz
tollen beitrag eines russischen
schriftstellers auf der faz und auch auf
faz ein spruch wie packe ich den artikel
packe ich sehr gerne in die schon mal
berichtet hat aus eigener anschauung was
eigentlich passiert wenn man in russland
auf die straße geht ja was wie man dann
verhaftet wird das ganze hat noch nicht
ich fand ich auch sehr sehr eindrücklich
habe mich auch fragt ob wir das
vielleicht wenn demnächst vertiefen
können weil der eigentliche vorgang ist
immer dann ganz erstaunlich
unspektakulär na also die sind ein paar
für ein paar stunden weg und tauchen
dann eben wieder aus werden dann wieder
freigelassen und so weiter aber stehen
dann natürlich unter beobachtung und
wieder in die polizisten kommen und die
familie auch belagern und nachfragen
fragen stellen und man einfach das
gefühl hat man ist dann in so einer
schleife drin und beim nächsten mal wird
vater und es wird wieder hat es wird es
das ist wirklich sehr sehr eindringlich
gewesen das möchte ich an dieser stelle
schlecht niemals diese unbedingte
leseempfehlungen hier aussprechen packe
ich gerne in die show notes sie hätte
hat im vergleich dazu ist doch so ein
bfh-urteil schon echt wieder richtig
launig oder das muss man sich ja auch
mal vor augen führen also bleibt uns
gewogen habt eine gute woche da draußen
und genau wir freuen uns über feedback
darunter einspruch podcast faz.de und
wünschen einen schönen rest woche bis
dahin tschüss
[Musik]